ces élèves de la classe orchestre du
collège des sas de guillancour viennent
de recevoir leurs instrument c'est leur
tout premier cours et pour l'instant ces
apprentis musiciennes essaient de faire
connaissance avec leur Flut
traversière c'est placer le petit toit
en fait ça fait très mal quand on
souffle dans la FL ça fait pas forcément
un bruit faut bien souffler dans le trou
la classe orchestre s'effectue sur 3
années jusqu'en classe de 3e les élèves
du collège des SAS suivent 2 heures de
cours par semaine la première en atelier
pratique la seconde en TTI le moment où
toutes les familles d'instruments violon
guitare basse percussions et flutes se
rassemblent pour former l'orchestre le
plaisir de jouer reste le maître mot car
les collégiens ne sont pas notés par
leurs professeurs dans un premier temps
avoir un joli son et puis maîtriser donc
la pose des doigts sur chaque clé voilà
ce qui va demander un petit certain
temps qui s jouer quelques notes qui
sache lire un petit peu les partitions
quelques rythmes mais le but c'est
vraiment de J
ensemble ces 20 apprentis musiciens
devront être prêts pour leur première
représentation officielle à la fin de
l'année scolaire en attendant ils se
sont déjà produ sur scène en chanson
lors de la cérémonie de remise des
instruments